hello there citizens of the reject nation
we are almost done with this show gravity
falls john how are you i am i'm i'm a little
saddened now but i'm gonna pray you know these
are precious speed it up john we gotta get two
i'm really excited to watch the show get through
we're gonna watch season two episode eleven what's
it called it's called it's not what he seems
all right good jeez let's take someone
to get there wasting time leave a like
wasting so much leave a like and subscribe stop
wasting time hit the notification bell and if you
wanna sync up with us with your own copy and
enjoy the full experience come to patreon.com
rejects we've got so many other shows where
the same tier you get reaction highlights
thank you prepper guys thank you and
and gals and all of you thank you for
cutting out these highlights let's
roll the bumper and start the show
come on come on should be just enough to finish
the job can't be too careful with this stuff
very homer simpson move stream usage
could result in minor gravity anomalies
can it poindexter i've come
this far i'm not giving up now
what we got here speaking of anomalies
the gravitational pull on this is enormous
the laptop
hey that's from the titles just 18 more hours
where's this going nowhere it will never
be revealed because for like 10 episodes
in a row you guys have been like oh
but the next episode's my favorite
shorter intro that's a good sign okay so i was
just opening random doors because i'm a creep when
i found something amazing if it was worth waking
up at 7am for that will be amazing a trailer
the lawsuit maker crazy rooftop
fireworks party not so fast kids
there is no way on earth you're setting off
those dangerous illegal fireworks without me
you have a permit for being totally lame
well i can't argue with that carry
on oh take that seriously though
we should probably clean this mess up
with water balloons i don't see why not
to grunkle stan not just a great uncle the
greatest uncle that grunkiest uncle it's
unnatural for siblings to get along as well
as you do don't worry we've still got plenty
of summer left to drive each other crazy
hey you got it i'm gonna go refresh my soda
enjoy while you can stan i'll find out sooner
or later today's the day what is that a ladybug
what the oh no i like how his hat creates a
slap effect target secure take the house no
i have a feeling nick offerman is about to return
clear
he's not some evil super villain we've been
watching your family all summer and we've seen
some disturbing things but nothing as dangerous
as what your uncle is hiding what trigger you take
the children i'll talk to the old man sorry to
break it to you kids but you don't know your uncle
at all i see punk pervert it's evidence ground
team move move break down the door or maybe not
it's a tag on the police station how do you plead
to these charges uh guilterson i mean in a guilty
um can i have my phone call got his
report card behind me humber jackson
that comes with a free toy mr pine is
this some sort of possession situation
time for a repair guy to become
a repair man sir your junior yum
yum baby time kiddo meal just put one in
my mouth let's do this are you not gonna
always wanted to do that in the meantime
enjoy some mindless reality tv designed
to pacify you and make you stop asking
questions i'm about to make the incision
there's no way stan was stealing
hazardous waste we gotta clear his name
wait a minute the security tapes didn't stan say
he was restocking the gift shop last night if we
could get the mystery sex no move he's innocent we
just need to think of a way out of here thank me
call back
cyril time stands yes backup requesting backup
come on dipper we're gonna go clear
our uncle's name now you've done it
minute they're playing with water balloons
the next they're building doomsday devices
your uncle scammed the whole world
you gonna let them scam you too
uncle scam you don't know what you're
talking about you're gonna regret this
good old safety protocols
they're getting stronger of course that's it
what are you doing to the town
it's happening the end times when that machine
activates i gotta get out of town get in there
raccoon wife oh timeless love mabel aren't
you forgetting the simpler solution oh right
so is it a rock or is it a face i think it's
a metaphor you're both right there it is stan
restocking like he said and the date shows
it was last night it's proof he's innocent
uh oh uh maybe he's just going to the
bathroom outdoors the way nature intended
and he's old so it would take hours
that could be anyone in that suit
god hot belgian waffles wait
i'm alone i can swear for real
so maybe grunkle stan stole some toxic waste that
doesn't mean he's leading a nefarious double life
mabel i'm not so sure about that
what whoa who are you i didn't need
these unless you were trying to hide your
real identity but why would stan do that
oh my god what stan pine's dead foul play
suspected in pine's death fiery car crash
breaks cut by who that evening is real
the real uncle yeah is he just posing
named grifter at large why would they
call him unnamed unless stan isn't stan
creepy that's pretty upsetting what the
secret code to hideout let me see that a1 b
c3 i've never seen a code like this
wait i have different vending machines
you've been running your whole life your time is
finally up bathroom break just give me 15 seconds
oh yeah so do you huh
wow dang stanception
oh my god he's brilliant
here's 100 bucks drive as far away from
the shack as possible and don't stop
when the cops start chasing you he's
getting away obviously follow that cow
all right seuss remember the plan protect the
machine earn stan's trust legally get adopted
by stan change name to stan jr sue what
are you doing here stan gave me a mission
to protect this machine and i thought i love
snacks zeus listen uh oh come on i don't want
to fight you guys this hurts me more than
it hurts you oh no more than it hurts you
oh wow
it's like something from a video
game or a dream what a nightmare
how would you make it back there in 10 minutes
maybe the reason he has all those fake ids is
because he is a master criminal and
this machine is his master plan uh
i was wrong the whole time the machine was
meant to create knowledge but it is too powerful
i was deceived and now it is too late the device
if fully operational could tear our universe apart
why would what the clock ever
reaches zero our universe is doomed
it's the final countdown just
like they always sung about
the agents were right we have to shut it down
why would someone do this what
knowledge could be worth this cost
turn
what is going on i don't even know who you
are look i know this all seems nuts but i
need that machine to stay on if you just let me
explain oh oh no you're really losing time man
holy [__] oh no what is going on
gravity rises
gravity ascending hurry shut it down
no mabel mabel wait stop zeus what are
you doing tell him what it's gonna do
i don't even know if you're my grunkle i wouldn't
believe you but then listen to me remember this
morning when i said i wanted to tell you guys
something t-minus 20 seconds what is this yeah
but trust me everything i've
worked for everything i care about
it's all for this family mabel what if he's lying
this thing could son of oh you're big dipper
mabel you really think i'm a bad guy he's
lying shut it down now mabel please ten nine
i wanna see what happens don't
shut it down yeah let it go
i trust you oh my god
what the hell this is wild
this is nipple chills right now
oh my god oh my god just took a whole new level
oh
is that stan
that's the guy's hand what extra
finger the author of the journals
yeah is this the part where one
of us faints oh i am so on it dude
it's them
oh wow a nice little epilogue it's kind of eerie
it is the brother being not mabel and dipper's
dad yeah a little pencil there yeah wow that was
a wild episode that was really chilling it was
intense like definitely not that funny but it was
just like mildly amusing with the comedy some good
laughs but yeah it was really like that actually
got like suspenseful yeah like what's gonna happen
and and it towards the tail end of that you know
it was while it was intense uh i was still there
going i don't want it i don't want them to push
the button i want it i want to see what happens
not even trust even if they
fail i to just see what happens
we built it up so much that we can not see it yeah
yeah yeah and then to have his brother be revealed
there at the end and then like to know the answers
are all connected to the family in some way it
doesn't like uncle sam ultimately does love them
and care about them yeah but i wonder if he's semi
evil or thwarted the brother like grunkle stan's
brother yeah maybe or else it's the kind of thing
where like he took up the mantle after some kind
of you know accident of some kind like i'm sitting
here going okay so is the car crash real did uh
you know the brother actually died somehow and
then he like took over his work to try and finish
it or was it like a jealousy thing or something
like i don't believe stan is like actually evil
but no no they wouldn't go that far no because
yeah he does seem to actually care about them
but at the same time you know maybe yeah maybe
it behooved him to take on the identity but i like
the little moments that you get whenever you could
see stan is actually really capable of being
this guy who is actually more clever and gifted
in fighting like when he's taking out the cops and
showing some like those uh i love characters like
that who you genuinely believe are like idiots are
dumb and then you come find out that oh never mind
they're actually one of that that's what makes
them deadly is this cover-up that they have yeah
and i thought that was really blue i didn't even
think he stole the the are the tanks or the uh
the barrels of yeah toxic waste yeah i didn't even
think he stole that i was like okay i mean we know
where he was but i don't think he actually went
and got those i didn't even think that he didn't
reveal that like oh [__] and then all and the
countless reveals that were doing with him it
was like some stranger thing [__] it really was
yeah yeah it felt like uh them opening up another
portal to the upside down or something like that
and to see like that it actually has what looked
like some pretty serious repercussions on like
the town and just the surrounding world like yeah
it crests into this level of like everything up
until now for the most part minus a couple things
with like bill cipher and stuff like that i've
been kind of contained whereas this is like this
this seems like things will never be the same
after the like next episode can't just be
like a fluffy fun you know adventure of the week
anymore but the universe didn't i mean obviously
the universe wasn't gonna i mean i don't actually
know about it obviously my mind was going like
so what if this like is a completely different
show for the next nine episodes um and i hope
it just stays serialized and we got like nine
episodes left right something like that i think
so yeah not too many now's the time because i mean
i don't know they've been building up this lore
slowly over time and again i don't know what
the uh i don't know how the structuring with the
network of like keeping you on and how long you
get to tell your story but i could absolutely see
like the gear being flipped like no no
now we're in the end game of the story
you know yeah yeah it felt really he's actually
getting emotional at the end like watching
uh dipper turn on stan like fighting
with him pushing him away zeus
even going in and like exciting against these
kids yeah just became like dramatic yeah like
real dramatic and the guy like even even the the
guy in the when they crashed the um you know van
and he's like you don't know your uncle i've seen
this a thousand times before all the lies you know
like it really and even even them finding the
evidence of like the car wreck like there are
some things that are like actually pretty serious
that like crest beyond again like the audience
i feel like this was originally intended
for it's just kind of weird to go from
when you look back at the first season and where
you're at here like i wish there were more of
these shades throughout the show i know right like
there there yeah there are lots of episodes where
you would never be the wiser that any of this
could be possible yeah and then occasionally
they'll throw in a thing of like well stan's acted
weird you know but uh yeah it does make me wonder
in that sense like how they initially theorized
all this because if it does kick into gear in like
the last nine or ten episodes is just all cereal
i'm like this is a fascinatingly structured show
yeah i know to be two seasons mostly sort
of episodic all based around this you know
twin peaksy shyamalan leadingly episodic yeah
yeah yeah because you would think it's all
episodic then you find out it's all connected
yeah and there are so many little things that
come back around and that's another thing too is
i keep wondering like okay so what have we seen
in the past that in the next several episodes is
gonna become like surprisingly important where it
didn't necessarily feel like it was at first or
things like that you know yeah all right [__]
well this was really cool this is a great one this
is really great it's very different you know it
keeps that's the way it keeps coming to mind yeah
because that was actually suspenseful i never got
a nipple chills watching this show hey but i was
like getting chills like this is really hefty
and then them all turning on on stan at the end
and then the desperation was just kind of wild
to behold it was like really cool camera work too
um the way they dealt with the gravitational pull
and um or was it called the i was watching the
anomalies yeah anomaly disruption or something
like that yeah and like oh yeah especially when
they're in the the uh holding cell and it's like
inception it's like all yeah it's like the camera
is floating around and you've lost kind of sense
of where the ground even is like there's
some really creative choices all throughout
the surprisingly and some good sight gags as
always all right oh next episode's called the
tale of two stans good to know good to know all
right guys well thank you so much for being here
um keep a lookout for our reaction to the
next one uh before we go let's do a patreon
jean jeter gene if there's a man of many secrets
at our patreon page i imagine that it's probably
you just considering the wide plethora
of knowledge and interest that you have
it seems like you would be the guy but beyond
that there is one thing you have not kept secret
which it is your birthday happy jean day happy
birthday gene jeter you've been part of our
patreon page for so long such a loyal guy and
we've had many conversations back and forth well
john and i individually with you and you have
been just an absolute pleasant understanding
gentleman and a wonderful artist as well so
thank you so much for just being you and all you
contribute to our lives to the arts and i'm sure
to the many people whose careers you've actually
helped elevate as well so seem like just a great
guy and whenever we make it out to the east coast
you'll be definitely getting hit up by us to go
hang out take you out for a drink go to a strip
club and then i'll get yelled at when i come back
home but i'll be worth it for the gene geeternator
make it rain on you gene and then we get on
there gene is kicked out kicked down push
those girls off the stage and show us your moves
gene see ya bud happy birthday happy birthday